Far Cry primal available February 23rd
[Music]
hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to a
prehistoric episode of reality check
when we travel back to the land before
time and certainly the land before video
games this episode is brought to you by
Far Cry primal which is dragging itself
out of the primordial development news
and coming out next week
you play as lonesome caveman - car
starting near the bottom of the paleo
food chain and you have to work your way
up to the top by building up a personal
menagerie crafting your own weapons and
forming a kick-ass tribe here on reality
check we're pretty guilty of only
talking about modern science and
technology I guess that's because in the
grand scheme of things all of the
interesting stuff has happened within
the last hundred years or so and because
it's pretty difficult to get information
from a time before written records and
hot take tweets
primal is set in a really key time in
human history it's the period when our
ancestors completely changed their way
of life so I thought I'd do some digging
what was Stone Age life actually like in
the periods at Far Cry primal set in how
did our ancestors actually live let's
find out the Stone Age lasted for over 3
million years and was split into three
ages the Paleolithic Mesolithic and
Neolithic the first the Paleolithic
lasted for over two million years and
accounts for about 90% of human
existence during this time humans
undertook a nomadic lifestyle always on
the move and getting food by hunting and
gathering they commonly use tools like
stone tipped Spears harpoons bows and
arrows and even rudimentary mechanical
devices like this at level
then at around 10,000 BCE that's before
the Common Era the earth went through
some changes
here's a quick geography lesson the
earth cycles between glacial periods at
an interval of time which lasts
thousands and thousands of years where
the earth is colder the resulting
glaciers lock away vast amounts of water
therefore lowering the sea level meaning
that early humans were able to travel to
all corners of the world interglacials
on the other hand are periods where the
earth is warmer hotter weather equals
higher sea level because all that water
that was locked away gets released again
we're in an interglacial right now
around 10,000 BCE the earth started
warming up and fun fact for you trivia
lovers our current period of geological
time is called the Holocene epoch and
it's the side of this epoch where far
cry primal is set the Mesolithic era a
true transitional period for our
ancestors with the warmer temperatures
forests sprung up we began to rely less
on hunting and gathering and turned to
agriculture planting crops and
domesticating animals like sheep this is
what allowed more people to settle into
villages like the ones you find in
Primal and speaking of domestication
Takhar in primal is a beast master able
to calm wild animals and give them
direct commands
sadly Mesolithic man probably didn't get
beast taming powers bestowed to him by a
shaman through finding various
fossilized dogs and human bones near
each other
archeologists believe we domesticated
dogs 15 thousand years ago
so while Jaguars may not have been
joining Mesolithic man while he goes
hunting man's best friend certainly did
after this period of transition we then
come to the Neolithic Age and most of
our food is sourced through agriculture
in fact these days are arguments that
maybe this move wasn't the best for us
hunter-gatherers had a more varied diet
and they definitely got more exercise I
mean I hear that fresh air things good
and all but I'd rather stay inside so we
know how our ancestors lived in 10,000
BCE but it's our way to find out what
they sounded like well to find out I
shanked with a husband-and-wife expert
team from the University of Kentucky
assistant professor of linguistics
Andrew bird and his system professor of
modern and classical languages
Brenna Byrd using the
proto-indo-european language which is a
reconstruction of an ancient language
believed to be used in 3500 BCE they
created a whole new language for Far Cry
primal it's called winter my my Josiah
wage a mana
Oh like wow so when you hear put under
European it sounds a lot like Latin
Greek for obvious reasons cuz I increase
income from it right so Lakes has sold
put lost quick soup no good told and so
when you hear that it sounds really kind
of classical you know and so what they
wanted to do what the dev team wanted to
do was to make it sound even older and
we made the decision to use proton to
European even further back as to say
proto proto-indo-european so if you find
certain old features of proto
indo-european we assume those to be the
basic features of window
not grab me it is bad there are certain
things that once you study how languages
change and you see you start to see
certain patterns and there are just
certain things that human languages do
there's certain patterns are certain
things that languages can do and cannot
do when they change and we kind of look
to those patterns and we base our
languages off of that the language
creation that actually was a very
collaborative a collaborative project we
did we worked a lot back and forth with
the writers to get something that worked
for the game but also is true to both
typology both how languages change and
how languages actually exist and also to
proto-indo-european what would be
possible what hey we didn't want to
continue this image of caveman as not
able to articulate himself what they
wanted to do was they wanted to make you
know these people people they're human
beings that laughs that tell jokes that
that struggle that you know love I mean
they they're just like us
without the technology and that's
basically it right anything that's
actually quote primitive right even for
societies that don't have that artist
technologically advanced as us they're
still able to express the same types of
thoughts and the most and in complicated
to us patterns it just might sound weird
when you're translating so hopefully
that'll fill some gaps in your knowledge
about primal life thanks for watching
don't forget I'm on Twitter at Lucy
James games and I'll see you next time
for some more reality check
[Music]